[Musique]
quand on pense au travail du député on a
immédiatement en tête les débats dans
l'hémis cyclés le vote de la loi mais le
rôle du député n'est pas seulement de
légiférer il a aussi un pouvoir de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
voir de le juger je vous explique le
député a d'abord pour mission de voter
la loi pendant les 50 son mandat ces
textes peuvent être des projets de loi
soumis par le gouvernement ou des
propositions de loi dont les députés
eux-mêmes sont à l'origine ils peuvent
aussi modifier les textes qu'ils
examinent en proposant au vote des
amendements
en cas de doute une fois la loi votée 60
députés peuvent saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel pour qu'il confirme ou
non que le texte est conforme à la
Constitution les députés ont aussi le
droit de demander des comptes au
gouvernement sur son action c'est un
droit reconnu par la Constitution et
qu'ils expriment notamment lors des
traditionnelles questions gouvernement
chaque mardi les députés ont la
possibilité d'interroger les membres du
gouvernement sur leur action publique ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre autre outil disponible la
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
des sujets de société ou sur la gestion
d'un service public elle dispose d'un
pouvoir important puisque les personnes
convoquées ont l'obligation de se
présenter de répondre aux questions sous
serment et de fournir tout élément
requis par la Commission
dernier recours un dixième des députés
peuvent déposer une motion de censure à
l'encontre du gouvernement si elle est
adopté le Premier ministre et son
gouvernement doivent démissionner 59
motions de censure ont été déposées sous
la Cinquième République mais une seule a
été approuvée en 1962 dans certains cas
assez exceptionnel des députés peuvent
aussi être amenés à rendre un jugement
au sein de deux institutions la Cour de
Justice de la République et la
Haute-Cour parmi les 15 juges de la Cour
de Justice de la République 6 sont des
députés leur rôle jugés les membres du
gouvernement sur des actes commis dans
l'exercice de leur fonction et jusqu'à
présent huit ministres et deux
secrétaires d'états ont été jugés
la Haute cour de son côté est composée
de l'ensemble des députés des sénateurs
ils peuvent voter la destitution du
président de la République en cas de
manquement à ses devoirs
[Musique]